it's like this little bottega veneta
pouch
i i'm wearing these like white cowboy
boots this is
miss alvara the cutout i've got these
little
things right here they're from the i
don't want it at all music video
queen kim petrus the last time we spoke
it was at the sold out
la stop of the broken tour now we're in
quarantine life has changed so
dramatically
how are you doing i'm doing good yeah
i'm doing i'm just
you know keeping positive there's days
where i don't feel positive
but um yeah but i feel like friends have
gotten me through it i just
like i talk to my parents and my family
i miss my family a lot
during this time i think um but i'm just
lucky
you know i i have a home set up i i can
record songs at home i can work from
home
um i can do this stuff from home
which is incredible because like it
would suck if
malibu just didn't get any promo just
because of this
you know
[Music]
i am declaring it preemptively the song
of summer
oh my god thank you so much it's so good
but first i gotta just like backtrack a
little i want to know where are you
quarantined and who are you with
i'm in chaluca lake and i'm with uh
aaron you've met aaron
last time he's my best friend since
about six years
um so i'm just happy i'm not alone
because i live by myself and my own
apartment
um and he's helped me like set up my
studio uh set up and uh we're recording
together and producing together and all
that stuff so
that's really cool um especially like
uh there's been like a lot of uh
collaborations and stuff like that
happening which is a great
thing about florentine people are just
collabs in quarantine
yeah for sure like a lot of people are
just you know sending around songs
they're making at home
and so i'm really really blessed in in
that regard and i
you know i'm working on my new album on
uh whatever album
malibu is going to land on and i really
want it to be a concept album so i feel
like i finally have
the time actually to do that i want to
ask you a few quarantine questions and
then we'll talk all about the music
i i have to tell you i've been watching
your instagram lives
and you've never failed to amaze me
with a snatched wing gorgeous hair
a full proper look yeah how much glam
are you doing in quarantine and
by the way do you have a makeup artist
in your house with you or is this all no
no this is this is me i i've been doing
my own makeup for stuff
for years um i
like usually when i'm in like the big
cities i get a makeup artist but always
on like on like tour i i do it myself a
lot of the time
it makes me feel sane to put on a rash
and uh
do my brows and all of that stuff like
it makes me feel like life is still
normal and i know on some days it's
hard but i really find it to be like one
of those things that just like makes me
feel good about myself and makes me feel
happy it's like you're
therapeutic sometimes to uh to do it
yeah well the other day you were like
i'm wearing a hat
these roots are a problem what am i
looking at here these roots look good
you're looking at a wig
honey um yeah no i can
i can do my own wigs uh i have a little
wig closet my hair broke off from doing
that
one bun hairstyle for like a year and a
half
and literally this side just like it all
broke off like
up here and um it sucked
and now my all my hair is like back to
this length and it's like we had to cut
the side off
several times so the length is fine but
what we will not do
is uh this long route not we're not
going to do that
okay not in this house
yes i know i've seen a lot of people go
uh
brunette a lot of uh my blonde friends
have gone brunette and i'm just trying
not to do it because i know how hard it
is to get back
to uh so i wanna know how much online
shopping has been going on
and can you show us any of these fun
fabulous purchases
um um
um how do i show you one second so
one of the things that i got on ebay
that i'm proud of is this little
um i've always wanted this bag um it's
like this little bottega veneta
coach yes those are everything i know
i'm really obsessed
with them so it's this cute little size
i love her
she's great and she's um
yeah i got around ebay um for
literally like uh i think like 300 or
something
i'm wearing this like this top i got
sent to me
it's little chihuahuas i'm wearing these
like
white cowboy boots right now they were
quarantined purchased
like my shopping has gone out of control
like i feel like
every day i uh just wake up
for a box outside of my door and it's
also keeping me very sane
[Music]
i don't mean to pry but it's not every
day we get to be in a pop star's home
um is there are there fun things around
your house that you could share with our
viewers who are so curious
i mean this is not my house it's aaron's
house but yes this is
miss alvara the cutout i was so lucky to
have her
on my turn up the light uh halloween
album
it really made it legit um here's
like did you buy the cutout you were
like i need to have more elvira in my
life
uh yes uh i mean uh yeah me and aaron
bought it and then erin got to keep it
i've got these little
things right here they're from the i
don't want it at all music video they're
like these little houses that i
step on in the music video i have a
little
uh she's the girl from uh clueless uh
i have a little sailor moon obsessed
with sailor moon
um yeah other than that it's just a
bunch of clothes and a studio and
stuff like that
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been waiting for this moment i've
just been
going through videos and videos and
videos of fan submissions because i'm
doing this
beach at home music video from malibu
where my fans are sending me clips of
them in bikinis
or on beach towels with beach bags with
sunglasses and cocktails and
so i've been reaching out to a lot of my
uh pop star
friends and a lot of them said yes and
i'm really really excited to like have
some of them in my video and i feel
really blessed
i want to know everything about malibu
was this a song that you were hanging on
to when you were waiting to release or
was this something
you literally created in quarantine no
uh we i've written the first demo for
this song about three years ago
um and it was never really perfect
uh there was always the hook which was
really really good but we could never
really figure out the other parts
so i would say there's been like 10 or
15 versions of the song
until this point now i think it's like
literally one of my best songs i've ever
made i really feel like it's up there
i consider heart to break probably to be
my other best one but i think this one
might be hard to break
i think i dropped 48 songs over the last
two years unbelievable yeah yeah um
so it's it's really cool um it feels
like the perfect song
to you know be the lead for my debut
album
sometimes as an artist i feel like
you're not even objective to your own
songs anymore you get a little caught up
with like but that song has this amazing
run in it or
i love this chord progression and all
that stuff that doesn't really matter
and i think malibu just really makes
everybody feel
good and that's all i want to do right
now
is just i want to make you feel like you
just went to the beach and like you're
about to have the funnest night of your
life and
uh that's all i want well damn i hope we
get out of quarantine so i can go
blasted up and down pch all summer i
know
i know same
[Music]
whose time taste like malibu
um well back in the day uh i was dating
this guy
who then ended up breaking my heart um
and
uh that's what i want clarity about so i
guess it's
about the i guess it's about that person
the song honestly is very much a love
song
to what i thought malibu would be and
what i
saw on tv and stuff when i was in
germany and i'd never been to america
until it was like 19
and i was just you know dreaming about
it and
when i got to malibu it was just like a
lot of rich people's houses
and it was honestly kind of
disappointing and uh
like i didn't think it was that exciting
like it just wasn't as like
amazing as i thought it would be and as
it wasn't like
baywatch or you know so you know the
the clarity project gave us
a lot of fields you gave us bops but you
you hit us with some songs that were
sad and about you know hardships that
you've gone through in your
relationships
is malibu a good indicator of what kp2
is gonna sound like is it gonna be a be
fun
happy joyful yes very
very much i think i'm i just don't feel
heartbroken anymore i feel very like
i i also don't feel bad about like not
having a personal life anymore i did for
a while it was like i need to have this
personal life
and i love my job i love like
eating breathing uh living
music like every day and uh it's really
just making me so happy like i don't
feel like i'm missing anything
so i think it's just gonna be it's gonna
be a lot about
uh me finding like happiness also within
myself
and uh within what i do and just
celebrating life and
you know just having fun and like dating
but like nothing scared not being in a
relationship
uh and that's my question is you're on a
you're on tour 365 days a year
for all intents and purposes yeah
married to a recording studio you're
always with your producer friends
how do you find time to date when you've
got such a busy career
that's the thing like i usually don't
like
i make out with people at random things
that i randomly meet at some random club
or something like yeah for sure you know
i'm
young and i have fun um and
like you know i meet people along the
way who i might like
but i really just don't feel like i'm
missing anything like i'm not like oh i
want to have a boyfriend
or i want to have a relationship you
know i feel very
content being young and having fun and
making music i love and perfecting my
craft
and working on being a songwriter and
becoming a better performer like all
these things right now are so much more
exciting to me than having a boyfriend
so that's a woman in 2020 thank you yeah
for sure and uh yeah i just don't feel
like i'm missing anything
i love it earlier in the interview you
teased that you know we've got time
quarantine everybody's in each other's
dms you've been working on music you've
been collaborating
can you give us one collaboration that
we can expect
oh my god um um
hey um sheesh
are into the girls in the mix yes
i would i would love to collaborate with
any of the and i'm still working on my
song that i'm sending to paris so i
guess that i can
that i can give you definitely i'm
finishing the song with paris i
feel so mad at myself i've been talking
about it for literally over a year
so is this a duet or is it something you
wrote and she'll perform
i wanted to be a duet like i would love
to do a
duet with her um i just wanted to be
right i wanted to read the right song
and i wanted to be really good
it's kind of an epitome of like the la
girl it's very much
uh yeah it's it's about shopping uh
which is uh my favorite topic ever to
sing about
and uh drops the whole signature kim
petrus treatment
yes for sure like i definitely like you
know i
i don't want to like give paris a song
that's like not finished like i want to
send her like the finished thing
and then see if she loves it and if she
wants to jump on it so
let's see it's exciting
princess perfection that's what it needs
to be
i have to let you go but can i ask you
for one favor before we go would you
sing us a little bit of malibu
sure yeah all right tell me how do
i get over you when your eyes are so
pacific
view yeah falling deep into cool
sound blue oh and all your kisses taste
like
and do your kisses taste like